♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> GOOD MORNING, AND WELCOME.
I INVITE YOU TO STAND IF YOU ARE
ABLE.
WITH DEEP GRATITUDE TO THE
QUINNIPIAC PEOPLE FOR THIS LAND
ON WHICH WE STAND, MY BELOVED
YALE FAMILY, I INVITE YOU TO
JOIN ME IN THE SPIRIT OF
PRAYER.
ALMIGHTY AND BRILLIANT CREATOR
FOUNT OF ALL LIFE
HERE WE STAND IN THE SPLENDOR
THIS MORNING MANY AND DIVERSE
EXPRESSIONS OF ONE LIVING
MYSTERY WHICH IS BEYOND ALL
TELLING.
WE ARE GATHERED FROM ALL PARTS
OF YOUR WORLD TO SERVE A SACRED
PURPOSE.
WE ARE THE CHILDREN OF
YESTERDAY'S YEARNINGS AND THE
EMBODIMENT OF TOMORROW'S
PROMISE.
ON THIS DAY, THE CONTINUING
CREATION OF OUR LIVES AWAITS US
WITH EVER-INCREASING HORIZONS OF
MEANINAND RPONSIBILITY.
IT IS OUR UNKNOWN NEXT.
LOVING GOD, HERE IN THIS PLACE
OF SUCH PRIVILEGE AND LEARNING
BLESS OUR HEARTS, OUR MINDS AND
OUR HANDS AS WE BEGIN.
MAY WE BE TIRELESS SEEKERS OF
YOUR TRUTH AND EVER GENTLE
CARRIERS OF YOUR LIGHT.
LET CURIOSITY FUEL US AND
COMPASSION GUIDE US AS THIS NEW
CREATION UNFOLDS.
AWAKEN US TO YOUR GENIUS IN TH
MIDST OF ANCIENT CONVERSATIONS,
CONTEMPORARY TEXTS, FOSSILS AND
FORMULAS.
INSTILL IN US A LIFELONG THIRST
TO KNOW MORE AND IN TURN, TO
SHARE MORE.
FINALLY, MAY OUR LOVED ONES TAKE
PLEASURE IN THE CHANGES THEY
WILL SEE IN US.
AND MAY THEY BE PATIENT WITH THE
TWISTS AND TURNS THAT WILL NO
DOUBT BE BETWEEN WISH AND
FULFILLMENT IN THIS UNKNOWN
NEXT.
FOR ALL THAT IS SPOKEN ALOUD I
THIS POIGNANT LIFE MOMENT AND
FOR THAT WHICH RESTS SILENTLY IN
OUR HEARTS AS YOUR LOVING PEOPLE
WE SAY, AMEN.
PLEASE BE SEATED.
>> THANK YOU, CHAPLAIN KUGLER.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY, COLLEAGUES,
STUDENTS, FAMILIES, AND FRIENDS,
GOOD MORNING.
STUDENTS FROM THE DISEASE CLASS
OF 2026, TRANSFER STUDENTS AND
ELI WHITNEY STUDENTS, AND
VISITING INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS,
WELCOME TO YALE!
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND FAMILY MEMBERS AND FRIENDS
IN MY ROLE AS DEAN OF THE YALE
COLLEGE, I EXTENDS MY WARM
WELCOME TO YOU AS WELL, ALONG
WITH GRATITUDE FOR EVERYTHING
YOU HAVE DONE IN SUPPORTING AND
GUIDING THESE YOUNG ADULTS.
THE OPENING ASSEMBLY IS ONE of
MY FAVORITE FORMAL EVENTS OF TH
ACADEMIC YEAR BECAUSE IT
INTRODUCES US TO EACH OTHER,
JUST AS YOU, OUR NEW STUDENTS,
HAVE BEGUN INTRODUCING YOURSELF
VES TO YOUR FELLOW CLASSMATES.
AND I ALSO THINK OF IT LESS
FORMALLY, AS A CONVERSATION WITH
YOUR PEERS AND INSTRUCTORS THAT
WILL GO ON FOR MANY YEARS TO
COME.
YOU WILL FIND GREAT FELLOWSHIP
HERE, AND YOU ALSO WILL FIND THE
GREAT PLEASURE OF LEARNING.
AT THE BEGINNING OF HIS ANALECT,
THE CHINESE PHILOSOPHER
CONFUCIUS PROVIDES WORDS THAT
WERE5 HOUR YEARS AGO. AS THEY
HERE HE IS, AS THOUGH ADDRESSING
YOU NOW:
"IS IT NOT A PLEASURE TO LEARN
AND-WHEN IT IS TIMELY-TO
PRACTICE WHAT YOU HAVE LEARNED?
IS IT NOT A JOY TO HAVE FRIEND
COMING FROM AFAR" AND I AM
DELIGHTED TO WELCOME YOU, OUR
NEW STUDENTS, WHO COME FROM NEAR
OR FAR, TO EXPERIENCE THE
PLEASURE OF LEARNING TOGETHER.
YALE PROFESSOR ANNPING CHIN
EMPHASIZES THAT THE PURPOSE OF
LEARNING, FOR CONFUCIUS,
CONSISTED IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DEVELOP OUR MORAL AND AESTHETIC
SENSIBILITIES, TO FULFILL OUR
HUMANITY, AND TO DO SO WITH
HUMILITY.
IN A PARALLEL WITH SOCRATES, WHO
LIVED ABOUT A CENTURY LATER, WE
KNOW MOST OF WHAT CONFUCIUS
TAUGHT THROUGH THE ACCOUNTS OF
HIS DISCIPLES.
WHO ALWAYS REPRESENT THE GREAT
PHILOSOPHER IN CONVERSATION. IN
FACT, THE MEANING OF THE CHINES
TITLE OF THE ANALECTS, "LUNYU,"
IS "CONVERSATIONS" OR
"DIALOGS.  "
LIKE THESE ANCIENT THINKERS, THE
COMMUNITY YOU ARE NOW JOINING
LEARNS THROUGH DIALOG.
THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION CAN ALLOW EACH OF
US TO DEVELOP OUR OWN
SENSIBILITIES AND FULFILL OUR H.
THE YALE COLLEGE COMMUNITY HAS
LONG HISTORY, SHAPED BY THE MAN
GENERATIONS OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE
COME BEFORE YOU.
AND THIS WEEK, MORE THAN 1500 OF
YOU HAVE COME TO NEW HAVEN FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
NO SINGLE RACIAL OR ETHNIC GROUP
IS A MAJORITY IN THIS VERY
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY.
ALMOST A FIFTH OF YOU WILL BE
THE FIRST GENERATION IN YOUR
FAMILIES TO GRADUATE FROM A
4-YEAR COLLEGE, ABOUT A FIFTH O
YOU HAVE RECEIVED PELL GRANTS
FOR LOWER-INCOM STUDENT
128 OF YOU APPLIED THROUGH THE
QUESTBRIDGE PROGRAM, AND 47 WE
ADMITTED THROUGH THE TRANSFER
AND ELI WHITNEY STUDENTS
PROGRAM.
13 OF YOU ARE MILITARY VETERANS,
AND 21 OF YOU BEGAN YOUR COLLEGE
EDUCATION AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
HEAR, HEAR!
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND TOGETHER YOU REPRESENT 51
STATES AND TERRITORIES OF THE
UNITED STATES AND MORE THAN 50
COUNTRIES.
AMIDST THIS GREAT DIVERSITY, YOU
ALSO SHARE MUCH IN COMMON.
YOU ARE PROMISING STUDENTS WITH
WIDE HORIZONS AND AN EXCITEMENT
ABOUT LEARNING.
WHEN I WROTE THIS SPEECH, I WAS
EXPECTING GOOD WEATHER.
I HOPE THE HORIZON WILL HOLD FOR
A LITTLE BIT LONGER.
TOGETHER, YOU HAVE COME TO YALE
TO PURSUE A BROAD, LIBERAL
EDUCATION.
YOU WILL FIND ONE HERE, IN BOT
FORMAL AND INFORMAL SETTINGS.
HERE WE STAND IN FRONT OF
STERLING MEMORIAL LIBRARY, THE
HEART OF CAMPUS, WHICH HOLDS
OVER 2 MILLION BOOKS IN ALL
PARTS OF KNOWLEDGE.
AND I WILL SAY, UNDERNEATH YOU
IS THE CROSS-CAMPUS LIBRARY,
WHICH IS A GREAT PLACE TO
STUDY.
TO GO UP INTO THE STACKS OF
STERLING, EVEN IF YOU'RE TO THE
GOING TO TAKE OUT ANY BOOKS, TO
GET A SENSE OF THE RANGE OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT IS OUT THERE AND
YOU MIGHT SOME DAY EXPLORE.
RECOGNIZING IN YOUR LIFETIME,
YOU WILL NOT MAKE IT THROUGH ALL
2 MILLION BOOKS.
BUT YOU WILL LEARN IN THE
CLASSROOMS AND DISCUSSIONS
SECTIONS THAT YOU FOR THE START
NEXT WEEK, THE LIBRARIES AND
GALLERIES AND LABORATORIES WHERE
YOU WILL BROADEN AND TEST WHAT
YOU HAVE LEARNED.
AND IN THE DESK OR CARREL THAT
YOU WILL CLAIM FOR SOLITARY
STUDY.
YOU WILL
EXPERIENCE THE LESS FORMAL PAR
OF YOUR EDUCATION WHEN YOU TALK
WITH THE PEOPLE AROUND YOU, IN
THE STUDENT GROUPS YOU JOIN,
WITH YOUR INSTRUCTORS DURING
THEIR OFFICE HOURS, OR WITH THE
STRANGER SITTING BESIDE YOU AT
THE LONG TABLE IN YOUR
RESIDENTIAL COLLEGE DINING HALL.
YALE'S TRADITIONS AND
COMMUNITIES FORM THEIR OWN CIVI
SOCIETY THAT RUNS PARALLEL TO
THE FORMAL CURRICULUM TAUGHT BIT
PROFESSOR.
OF COURSE, YOU ARE HERE FOR THE
FORMAL STUDY, BUT I WANT YOU TO
EXPLORE VARIOUS WAYS TO LEARN
OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM OR THE
LIBRARY.
THIS IS A CAMPUS DESIGNED, OFTEN
INTENTIONALLY, BUT SOMETIMES BY
HAPPY ACCIDENT,
FOR CONVERSATION. THE TALENTED
AND ENERGETIC PEOPLE YOU WILL
MEET HERE WILL HAVE SOME
INTERESTS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
YOURS.
YOU WILL HAVE THE SCHOLARLY
COMMUNITY THAT DEFINES THE
PURSUIT OF KNOWLEDGE IN A GREAT
UNIVERSITY.
YOU COME HERE KNOWING THE STATE
OF PUBLIC DISCOURSE IN OUR
POLARIZED SOCIETIES.
YOU KNOW ALREADY THAT AT TIMES
IT SIMPLY REAFFIRMS OUR EXISTING
BELIEFS, AT OTHER TES,
DEVOLVES INTO PARTISANSHIP OR
EVEN VIOLENCE.
UNIVERSITIES ARE NOT IMMUNE TO
DOGMA, BUT THEY ASPIRE TO A
HIGHER TYPE OF CONVERSATION.
AS YOU JOIN OR START YOUR OWN
CONVERSATIONS IN THE SEMESTERS
AHEAD, THINK ABOUT HOW YOU CAN
EXPANDS YOUR HORIZONS.
ONE OF THE DISTINCTIVE THINGS
ABOUT HUMAN EXPERIENCE IS EACH
OF US IS BORN IN A PARTICULAR
BODY AT A PARTICULAR TIME AND
PLACE.
AND THEREFORE WE SEE THE WORLD
FROM A GIVEN PERSPECTIVE.
BUT WE HAVE THE CHANCE TO EXPAND
OUR WORLD VIEW AS WE GROW AND
LEARN AND TRAVEL.
THE POET, TENNISON, HAS A
BEAUTIFUL IMAGE OF THIS IN THE
POEM YEWLY SEIZE.
HE WRITE WRITES, I'M A PARTS OF
ALL I HAVE MET,:  I AM A
PART OF ALL THAT I HAVE MET; /
YET ALL EXPERIENCE IS AN ARCH
WHERETHRO' / GLEAMS THAT
UNTRAVELL'D WORLD WHOSE MARGIN
FADES / FOR EVER AND FOREVER
WHEN I MOVE."
THERE IS ALWAYS SOMETHING TO
LEARN JUST OVER THE HORIZON.
WH
WAY TO GET HERE OR WHETHER YOU
HAVE LIVED ALL YOUR LIFE IN NEW
HAVEN, YOU MAY FEEL THAT SENSE
OF AN EXPANDING HORIZON AS YOU
MEET NEW FRIENDS AND EXPLORE NE
INTELLECTUAL TERRITORY.
I HAVE SPENT ALMOST HALF MY LI
AT YALE, SO I SEE THE WORLD FRO
A VERY PARTICULAR VANTAGE POINT.
BUT I HAVE ALSO SPENT A LOT OF
TIME THINKING ABOUT HOW
EDUCATION ALLOWS US TO
TRANSCEND THE LIMITS OF OUR
HORIZONS.
IN HIS BOOK, TRUTH AND METHOD,
AN IMPORTANT BOOK ABOUT
HISTORICAL INTERPRETATION, THE
GERMAN PHILOSOPHER HANS-GEORG
GADAMER WROTE THAT "THE HORIZON
IS THE RANGE OF VISION THAT
INCLUDES EVERYTHING THAT CAN BE
SEEN FROM A PARTICULAR VANTAGE
POINT," AND HE ARGUED THAT
UNDERSTANDING INVOLVES WHAT HE
CALLED A "FUSION OF HORIZONS" I
WHICH WE BECOME MORE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT HOW OUR OWN ASSUMPTIONS
AND THE WAY WE SEE THINGS
CORRESPOND TO AND
RELATE TO SOMEONE ELSE'S VANTAE
POINT.
FOR GADAMER, INTERPRETING AN
ANCIENT TEXT OR HAVING A
CONVERSATION OR DIALOGUE WITH
ANOTHER PERSON INVOLVES OPENING
OURSELVES TO REASSESSING OUR OW.
ASSUMPTIONS.
HE FOCUSES ON INTERPERSONAL AN
HUMANISTIC KNOWLEDGE, BUT A
SIMILAR PROCESS IS AT WORK IN
TESTING SCIENTIFIC HYPOTHESES.
IN FACT, THE WORK OF
UNDERSTANDING, AND EVEN JUST TH
WORK OF LIVING IN THIS WORLD,
INVOLVES A CONSTANT MENTAL
JOURNEY THROUGH TIME AND SPACE
THAT DEVELOPS OUR VIEWS AND
CHANGES OUR HORIZONS-A JOURNEY
LIKE THE ONE THAT ULYSSES MADE,
WHAT
THE GREEK CALL AN ODYSSEY.
IT INVOLVES AN ONGOING
METAPHORICAL
CONVERSATION WHERE WE QUESTION
OUR OWN ASSUMPTIONS AND
PREJUDICES THROUGH OUR
ENCOUNTERS WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
IDEALLY, IF WE ARE OPEN TO
GROWING, WE CAN TALK TO PEOPLE
WHOSE STANDPOINTS DIFFER FROM
OURS, AND WE N LEARFROM
THESE CONVERSATIONS.
A CRUCIAL, EVEN A DEFINING
PREREQUISITE, OF LEARNING AT THE
COLLEGE LEVEL, IS THE
WILLINGNESS TO
OPEN OURSELVES TO VIEWS AND
IDEAS - AND EVEN WAYS OF LIFE -
THAT CHALLENGE OUR ASSUMPTIONS,
EITHER SO WE CAN LEARN TO
UNDERSTAND AND DEFEND THEM, OR
IN SOME CASES TO CHANGE OR
TO REASSESS THOSE ASSUMPTIONS.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT YOU NEED
TO ACCEPT EVERY IDEA THAT YOUR
PEERS OR PROFESSORS PROPOSE TO
YOU.
BUT IN THE YEARS AHEAD, YOUR J
WILL BE TO CONSIDER THE NEW
IDEAS YOU ENCOUNTER WITH AN OPE
ARGUMENTS, AND ARRIVE AT YOUR
OWN VIEWS ABOUT MATTERS OF GREA
IMPORTANCE FOR YOURSELVES AND
FOR YOUR FUTURES.
MATTERS SUCH AS THE NATURE OF
JUSTICE, THE UNDERSTANDING OF
THE NATURAL WORLD, THE MEANING
OF ART.
THE PURPOSES OF LIFE.
YOU WILL EXPLORE THESE QUESTIO
NOT ONLY IN YOUR CLASSES BUT
ALSO OVER MEALS IN YOUR DINING
HALLS, ON THE ATHLETIC FIELDS,
IN YOUR CAMPUS JOBS WITH INCOME
YOUR STUDENT ORGANIZATIONS, AS
VOLUNTEERS SERVING THE
COMMUNITY.
OR IN OF THE MANY PURSUITS OPEN
TO YOU AS A STUDENT.
ONE OF THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEARN AT YALE
COMES FROM THE "PEER EFFECT IF
THE.
THE CHANCE TO INTERACT WITH
OTHER TALENTED PEOPLE YOUR OWN
AGE.
THE NIGERIAN NOVELIST
CHIMAMANDA ADICHIE, WHO HAPPEN
TO HAVE RECEIVED HER MASTER'S
DEGREE AT YALE, OFFERS A SIMILA
VISION TO GADAMER'S WHEN
DISCUSSING LEARNING ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE'S EXPERIENCES, ESPECIALL
IN THE CONTEXT OF LIVING IN A
COLLEGE COMMUNITY.
SO, GADAMER FOCUSES ON
UNDERSTANDING DIFFERENT HORIZO
THROUGH TIME AND HISTORY,
ADICHIE EMPHASIZES LISTENING TO
DIFFERENT STORIES THROUGH SPACE
AND GEOGRAPHY.
IN HER SPEECH ON "THE STAGER OF
A SINGLE STORY,," SHE TELLS OF
ARRIVING AT THE OF 19 AT ANOTHER
FINE AMERICAN UNIVERSITY -- I
WON'T MENTION THE NAME OF THE
UNIVERSITY.
WHERE HER ROOMMATE
KNEW NOTHING ABOUT NIGERIA AND
MADE STEREOTYPICAL ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT ADICHIE'S HOMELAND AND WAY
OF LIFE.
AT FIRST, ADICHIE WAS
ANNOYED AT HER ROOMMATE'S LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING. AFTER SPENDIN
SOME TIME IN THE UNITED STATES,
HOWEVER, AND THINKING ABOUT HER
OWN LIMITED EXPERIENCE OF RURAL
PARTS OF NIGERIA, ADICHIE CAME
TO REALIZE THAT HER ROOMMATE'S
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT AFRICA WERE
MORE ACCATE STORIES ABOUT TO
AFRICA.
ADICHIE GOES ON TO TELL
BOTH POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE
STORIES OF HER CHILDHOOD AND
THEN SAYS: "ALL OF THESE STORIES
MAKE ME WHO A.
BUT TO INSIST
ON ONLY THESE NEGATIVE STORIES
IS TO FLATTEN MY EXPERIENCE AND
TO OVERLOOK THE MANY OTHER
STORIES THAT FORMS ME.
THE SINGLE STORY CREATES
STEREOTYPES, AND THE PROBLEM
WITH STEREOTYPES IS NOT THAT
THEY ARE UNTRUE, BUT THAT THEY
ARE INCOMPLETE.
THEY MAKE ONE STORY BECOME THE
ONLY STORY."
S CONCLUDES THAT "IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO ENGAGE PROPERLY
WITH A PLACE OR A PERSON WITHOU
ENGAGING WITH ALL OF THE STORIE
OF THAT PLACE AND THAT PERSON."
IT IS ALL TOO EASY TO MAKE
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT OTHERS WE
MEET, OR TO TAKE OFFENSE AT
ASSUMPTIONS OTHERS MAKE ABOUT
US, BUT OUR GOAL IS TO ENGAGE I
DIALOGUE SO THAT WE CAN OVERCOM
INITIAL MISUNDERSTANDINGS AND
LEARN FROM ONE ANOTHER.
AS YOU SETTLE INTO YOUR
RESIDENTIAL COLLEGES AND BEGIN
YOUR CLASSES, I INVITE YOU TO
PARTICIPATE IN A DIALOG.
LIKE CONFUCIUS, ENJOY THE
PRESSURE OF LEARNING.
LIKE ULYSSES, SEEK OUT NEW
LIKE GADAMER, STRIVE TO EXPAND
YOUR HORIZON OF EXPECTATIONS.
LIKE ADICHIE,
EXPLORE THE COMPLEXITY OF OTHE
PEOPLE'S STORIES, SHARE YOUR
OWN, AND CREATE NEW STORIES
TOGETHER.
YOU MAY FIND THE MOST
INTERESTING CONVERSATIONS IN
SEMINARS OR LAB MEETINGS, OR YO
MAY FIND THEM IN YOUR
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES, OR
LATE AT NIGHT IN THE COLLEGE
BUTTERY.
YOU WILL FIND THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WHERE YOU SEEK
THEM.
IN ORDER TO SUCCEED, I ASK YOU
TO OPEN YOURSELVES TO LEARN FROM
EACH OTHER.
SPIRIT OF GENEROSITY. NVERSATI A
ASSUME GOOD INTENTIONS.
VALUE COMPLEXITY AND NUANCE OV
SELF-ASSURANCE AND STEREOTYPE.
THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF YOUR YALE
EDUCATION.
THE LESSONS THEY TEACH YOU WILL
SHOW YOU HOW TO DEVELOP AS HUMAN
BEINGS.
AND THEY WILL SHOW YOU THOUSAND
HAPPY THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
SHAPE OUR SOCIETY.
THANK YOU.
AND WELCOME TO YALE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪
♪ FROM THIS BRIGHT HOUR AND DAYS
TO COME ♪
♪ AS WE HAVE GATHERED INTO ONE
♪
♪ OPEN THE GATES AND THE LIGHT
WILL SHINE ♪
♪ ALL AROUND, LET THERE BE LIGHT
♪
♪ ALL ARE WELCOME ♪
♪ ALL INVITED TO OPEN HEARTS AND
OPEN MINDS ♪
♪ IN OUR LIVING, IN OUR
SEARCHING FOR TRUTH AND LIGHT ♪
♪ WOUNDS OF THE WORLD BEGIN TO
HEAL AS PEACE WITH JUSTICE IS
MADE REAL ♪
♪ OPEN THE GATES AND THE LIGHT
WILL SHINE ♪
♪ ALL AROUND, LET THERE BE LIGHT
♪
♪ ALL ARE WELCOME, ALL INVITED
TO OPEN HEARTS AND OPEN MINDS ♪
♪ IN OUR LIVING, IN OUR
LEARNING, MAY WE ALWAYS BE
SEARCHING FOR TRUTH AND LIGHT ♪
♪ NOW IS THE HOUR, JOIN IN THE
SONG, HERE IN THIS PLACE WHERE
WE BELONG ♪
♪ OPEN THE GATES AND THE LIGHT
WILL SHINE ♪
♪ ALL AROUND, LET THERE BE LIGHT
♪
♪ ALL ARE WELCOME,LL INVITED
TO OPEN HEARTS AND OPEN MINDS ♪
♪ IN OUR LIVING, IN OUR
LEARNING, MAY WE ALWAYS BE
SEARCHING FOR TRUTH AND LIGHT ♪
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: GOOD MORNING,
EVERYONE.
THANK YOU, DEAN LEWIS, FOR THOSE
INSPIRING REMARKS.
IT IS TRULY A THRILL TO WELCOME
ALL OF YOU.
OUR ENTERING STUDENTS AND YOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS TO TO OUR CAMPUS
FOR OUR YALE COLLEGE OPENING
ASSEMBLY.
TODAY IS THE OFFICIAL F
YOUR UNDERGRADUATE EDUCATION AT
YALE.
AND ON BEHALF OF ALL MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE STAGE
WITH ME, WE'RE DELIGHTED THIS
DAY HAS ARRIVED.
AS YOU KNOW, YALE'S MOTTO IS
"LIGHT AND TRUTH."
IN LATIN -- IN HEBREW.
AND YOU WILL SEE IT ETCHED
UBIQUITOUSLY ON CRESTS AROUND
CAMPUS.
TODAY I WANT TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ABOUT THE PART OF OUR MOTTO WE
SHARE WITH MANY OTHER
UNIVERSITIES AROUND THE WORLD
THROUGH THEIR MISSION, ETHOS,
CULTURE.
AND THAT IS:  VERITAS.
OR TRUTH.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW, EVEN AS
THE WORLD STRUGGLED TO CONTAIN A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS, WE HAVE
WITNESSED THE VIRULENT SPREAD OF
DECEPTIVE INFORMATION.
EVEN OUTRIGHT LIES.
WE HAVE SEEN AN ASSAULT ON
EXPERTISE.
AN ASSAULT OSCIENTIFIC AND
OTHER.
INDEED, AN ASSAULT ON TRUTH.
HARDLY A DAY PASSES WITHOUT A
REPORT ON SOMEONE WHO DISCOVERED
IN THE COMFORT OF HIS OR HER OWN
HOME THAT THE SCIENTIFIC EXPERTS
ARE WRONG ABOUT COVID.
HARDLY A DAY GOES BY WHEN
SOMEONE ON THE INTERNET DOES NOT
SPIN SOME NEW FACT-FREE
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
HISTORICAL EVENTS WE KNOW TO BE
TRUE ARE DENIED BY INDIVIDUALS
WITH NEFARIOUS MOTIVES.
HERE ARE FIVE BRIEF EXAMPLES.
EARLIER THIS YEAR SOME IN OUR
COUNTRY -- INCLUDING THOSE IN
POSITIONS OF LEADERSHIP --
DEPICTED A VIOLENT MOB'S ATTEMPT
TO DISRUPT THE MOST BASIC
FUNCTIONING OUR DEMOCRACY BY
DENYING AN ELECTION OUTCOME AS
LEGITIMATE POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
AS DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES, SEVERE
DROUGHT IN SOME PLAS, HISTORIC
FLDING IN OTHERS PORTEND A
CATASTROPHIC CLIMATE EMERGENCY,
WE SEE THOSE FATEFUL TO
UNFOUNDED SKEPTICISM DISREGARD
OVERWHELMING SCIENTIFIC
CONSENSUS.
IN SOME COUNTRIES IN THE UNITED
STATES, HALF OF THE RESIDENTS
STILL DO NOT BELIEVE GLOBAL
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL.
IN RECENT MONTHS, VLADIMIR PUTIN
HAS PROPAGATED MISINFORMATION
ABOUT ROOTING OUT NAZIS AS THE
MOTIVATION FOR HIS UNPROVOKED
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS HAVE BEEN
MOBILIZED TO INCITE OR STOKE
ETHNIC VIOLENCE BY PROPAGATING
FALSEHOODS IN COUNTRIES LIKE
MYANMAR AND ETHIOPIA.
AND FINALLY, A RECENT DEFAMATION
TRIAL FOCUSED ON A NOTORIOUS
CONSPIRACY THEORIST WHO CLAIMS
THAT THE MURDER OF 20 SCHOOL
CHILDREN AND 6 ADULTS IN SANDY
HOOK, CONNECTICUT, ABOUT A HALF
HOUR'S DRIVE FROM HERE WAS
AGED BY THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
OF COURSE, SPREADING
MISINFORMATION IS NOT NEW.
HISTORY TEEMS WITH THE HAUNTING
CONSEQUENCES OF LIES.
PHILOSOPHER HANNAH ARENDT ON WHO
YALE BESTOWED AN HONORARY DEGREE
IN 1971 WRITES OF SOME OF
HUMANITY'S DARKEST CHAPTERS AND
THE MALIGNANT REGIMES THAT
AUTHORED THE
THE IDEAL SUBJECT OF TOTALTARIAN
RULE, SHE SAYS, IS NOT THE
CONVINCED NAZI OR THE CONVINCED
COMMUNIST.
IT IS, RATHER, PEOPLE FOR WHOM
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN FACT AND
FICTION -- THAT IS THE REALITY
OF EXPERIENCE, AND THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN TRUE AND
FALSE -- THAT IS THE STANDARDS
OF THOUGHT -- NO LONGER EXIST.
YES.
MALEVOLENCE CAN FEAST ON THE
ENVIRONMENT DEVOIDF VERITAS.
AND AT STAKE, THEREFORE, IN THE
ABIDING SEARCH FOR TRUTH IS
HUMANITY ITSELF.
FOR OUR PART, COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES MUST COMBAT THE
SPREAD OF MISINFORMATION,
PROPAGANDA, AND CONJURED
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
FIRST, BY SUPPORTING FACULTY.
THEY GENERATE SCIENTIFIC DATA
AND SCHOLARLY INSIGHT.
FACULTY MUST BE FREE TO
DISSEMINATE KNOWLEDGE AND TEACH
YOU TO THINK CRITICALLY ABOUT
IDEAS AND THEIR SOURCES.
BUT TO DO SO EFFECTIVELY, OUR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION, FACULTY, AND STUDENTS
MUST BE OPEN TO ENGAGING WITH
DIVERSE IDEAS.
WHETHER CONVENTIONAL OR
UNCONVENTIONAL.
OF THE LEFT OR OF THE RIGHT.
IT IS YALE'S OBLIGATION TO
ADDRESS THE CREDIBILITY CRISIS.
FOR WE HAVE LONG STOOD FOR THE
PURSUIT OF TRUTH AND DEVOTED
OURSELVES TO IT.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES LIKE
YALE ARE HOME TO ARTISTS AND
SCHOLARS AND SCIENTISTS AND
PRACTITIONERS WHO SPEND THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES SEARCHING FOR
TRUTH.
YET, THE GROWING POLARIZATION IN
SOCIETY AROUND IDEAS SPOKEN OF
BY YOUR DEAN, WHETHER EMBRACED
OR ESCEWED BY A PARTICULAR
FACTION THREATS EXPERTISE,
MINIMIZING THE IMPACT OF
UNIVERSITIES.
PRECISELY WHEN UNVARNISHED TRUTH
IS S SEPARATY NEEDED.
FACULTY AND STUDENTS, UNDERSTOOD
THE UNIVERSITY ITSELF, WILL BE
VIEWED AS RELIABLE SOURCES OF
INFORMATION IF WE DO NOT APPEAR
CLOSED OFF TO UNPOPULAR OR
OTHERWISE NON-MAINSTREAM IDEAS
FROM THOUGHTFUL INDIVIDUALS
RESPONSIBLY ARTICULATED.
MOST AMERICANS STILL HAVE A
POSITIVE VIEW OF UNIVERSITIES
AND CONSIDER A COLLEGE EDUCATION
IMPORTANT FOR FUTURE SUCCESS.
BUT COIDENCE TT HIGHER
EDUCATION HAS A IMPACT ON
SOCIETY IS ERODED BY A BELIEF
THAT WE WILL NOT ENGAGE WITH
IDEAS THAT CHALLENGE US.
SO, LET ME DISCUSS A FAMILIAR
EXAMPLE.
THAT THERE HAS BEEN A STEADY
DECLINE IN THE PERCENTAGE OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO BELIEVE THE
FREEDOM TO EXPRESS UNPOPULAR
POINTS OF VIEW IS SECURE.
ACTUALLY, IT IS A MYTH THAT
STUDENTS DO NOT WANT THEIR
CAMPUSES TO BE HOME TO A BROAD
RANGOF PERSPECTIVES.
THEY DO.
RECENT OPINION POLLING BY THE
THE KNIGHT FOUNDATION CONFIRMS
MOST STUDENTS BELIEVE IT IS MORE
IMPORTANT TO BE EXPOSED TO ALL
TYPES OF SPEECH, THAN TO PROTECT
PEOPLE BY PROHIBITING OFFENSIVE
OR BIASED SPEECH.
WHAT SOME REFER TO AS "CANCEL
CULTURE," IS NOT THE DOMINANT
IDEOLOGY OF STUDENTS.
HERE AT YALE, WHICH IS HOME TO
THE COUNTRY'S OLDEST COLLEGIATES
DEBATE SOCIETYSTUDENTS ACROSS
THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM CAN
ENGAGE IN SPIRITED, YET CIVIL
DISCUSSIONS.
YALE COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE
SELECTED HILLARY CLINTON AS A
CLASS DAY SPEAKER AND HONORED
BOTH GEORGE H.W. BUSH AND GEORGE
W. BUSH AS YALE UNDERGRADUATE
LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AWARD
RECIPIENTS.
AND THE UNIVERSITY HAS HOSTED
INTERACTIONS WITH INDIVIDUALS
WITH IDEOLOGICAL DIFFERENCES.
SUCH AS A RECENT CONVERSATION
BETWEEN EMILY AND ROZ, AND
ANOTHER BETWEEN FOUR FORMER
SECRETARIES OF STATE.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
BUT LET'S BE FRANK.
IT CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
ARTICULATE UNPOPULAR VIEWS ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THAT KNIGHT FOUNDATION SURVEY
THEY CITED A MOMENT AGO,
SUGGESTS THAT ONLY ABOUT HALF OF
ALL STUDENTS FEEL COMFORTABLE
OFFERING DISSENTING OPINIONS.
SO, WE NEED TO BUILD ON AN
EXISTING DESIRE AMONG STUDENTS
TO ENGAGE EVERY DAY IN
CLASSROOMS, IN DINING HALLS, IN
MEET MEETING SPACES WITH
DIFFERENT VIEWPOINTS.
AND TO APPRECIATE THE IMPORTANCE
OF EXPRESSING THEIR DISAGREEMENT
WITH ONE ANOTHER.
INDEED, IN A UNIVERSITY SETTING,
WE MUST BE ABLE TO DISTINGUISH
EMPHATICALLY LEGITIMATE DISSENT
FROM OUTRIGHT DECEIT.
WE MUST MAKE ROOM FOR BELIEFS WE
FIND OBJECTIONABLE AS FAITHFULLY
AS WE REJECT FALSEHOODS WE KNOW
TO BE LIES.
AND WE MUST THEREFORE NURTURE A
BIAS TOWARD OPENNESS.
EVEN -- AND ESPECIALLY -- WHEN
THIS ETHOS EXPOSES US TO POINTS
OF VIEW THAT TEST OUR MOST
STRONGLY-HELD ASSUMPTIONS.
SUCH A CLIMATE AFFORDS THE
SEARCH FOR TRUTH.
AND THE CREDIBILITY NECESSARY TO
TRUST IT.
OF COURSE, AS WE SEARCH FOR
TRUTH, WE MUST BE MINDFUL OF THE
POWER AND INFLUENCE OF
INSTITUTIONS LIKE YALE.
WEUST RECOGNIZE WITH HUMILITY
THAT WHAT LOOKS LIKE A TRUTH
MIGHT NOT BE ONE.
I THINK, FOR INSTANCE, OF OUR
OWN HISTORY.
OUR RESISTANCE TO CO-EDUCATION
FOR SO LONG.
OR OUR LEADERSHIP AT ONE TIME IN
EUGENICS.
WITH POWER COMES GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
THESE DISTURBING REALITIES ARE
WHY SOME ARE RELUCTANT EVEN TO
USE THE WORD "TRUTH" IN
DESCRIBING OUR MSION.
NONETHELESS, AT YALE, I'VE OFTEN
OBSERVED OUR FACULTY -- OUR
FACULTY ACTIVELY ENCOURAGING
STUDENTS TO INTERROGATE DATA AND
OTHER IDEAS PRESENTED TO THEM.
AND I HAVE SEEN STUDENTS CHANGE
THEIR MINDS WHEN CONFRONTED WITH
CONTRARY EVIDENCE.
EVERY ONE OF YOU WILL HAVE THAT
EXPERIENCE AS PART OF YOUR YALE
EDUCATION.
I SUSPECT YOU'LL HAVE IT OFTEN.
YOU CAN ENROLL IN COURSES THAT
BRING TOGETHER PAIRS OF
PROFESSO REPRESENTING
DIFFERENT DISCIPLINES WHO MODEL
HOW LOOKING AT A PROBLEM FROM
DIVERGENT PERSPECTIVES CAN LEAD
TO NEW INSIGHTS.
A COURSE ON FILM TAUGHT BY A
FILM HISTORIAN AND A PHYSICIST.
A COURSE ON THE NATURE OF CHOICE
TAUGHT BY A PHILOSOPHER AND AN
ECONOMIST.
A COURSE ON TRANSGENDER HEALTH
TAUGHT BY FACULTY MEMBERS FROM
AMERICAN STUDIES AND THE SCHOOL
OF NURSING.
SIMILARLY, IN A RECENT SEMESTER,
THREE EXPERTS FROM AOSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM CO-TAUGHT A
COURSE ON THE CRISIS OF
LIBERALISM.
COVERING THE OBAMA AND TRUMP
PRESIDENCIES.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THESE FOR
YOU.
TO HAVE OPEN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
CONTENTIOUS, COMPLEX ISSUES.
OPPORTUNITIES ROOTED IN THE
REALITY THAT NO IDEOLOGICAL
BLOCK CAN CLAIM OWNERSHIP OF
TRUTH.
THAT FACTS PLEDGE NO FEMALE --
NO FEALTY TOFULLY OF OUR
PREFERRED CONCLUSIONS.
THAT EVIDENCE MUST GUIDE THE
BELIEFS WE HOLD RATHER THAN
CONFORM TO THEM.
IN CONSIDERING THIS IMPERATIVE,
I'M REMINDED OF THE BOOK "THE
DEATH OF TRUTH" BY KAKATANI,
WINNER OF THE PULITZER PRIDE,
AND ALUMNUS OF YALE.
THE STIRRING APPEAL FOR REASON
AND OBJECTIVITY CONCLUDES WITH
AN ESPECIALLY, IF NOT
UNNERVINGLY RELEVANT WARNING FOR
OUR ERA ISSUED BY JAMES
MADISON.
A POPULAR GOVERNMENT WITHOUT
POPULAR INFORMATION OR THE MEANS
OF ACQUIRING IT IS BUT A
PROLOGUE TO A FORCE -- I'M
SORRY -- IS BUT A PROLOGUE TO A
FARCE OR A TRAGEDY.
OR PERHAPS BOTH.
INDEED, WITHOUT COMMONLY-AGREED
UPON FACTS, KAKATANI POSITIVE
ITS -- POSITS, NOT REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRATIC FACTS, NOT THE FACTS
OF TODAY'S SILOED WORLD, NO
RATIONAL DEBATED ABOUT POLICIES,
NO WAY TO EVALUATE PUBLIC OFFICE
AND NO WAY TO HOLD PUBLIC
OFFICIALS ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PEOPLE.
WITHOUT TRUTH, DEMOCRACY IS
HOBBLED.
THE FOUNDERS RECOGNIZED THIS.
AND THOSE SEEKING DEMOCRACY'S
SURVIVAL MUST RECOGNIZE I
TODAY.
THAT WAS ALL A QUOTE FROM
KAKUTANI.
I THINK OF JAMES HATCH, AN
EXTRAORDINARY YALE
UNDERGRADUATE, WHO SPENT TWO
DECADES WITH THE NAVAL WARFARE
COMMAND BEFORE RETURNING TO
COMPLETE HIS EDUCATION.
HAS HE WROTE:  THE CLIMATE AT
YALE IS WHERE ALL STUDENTS HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND THERE HAS TO BE A
PLACE WHERE PEOPLE CAN ASSAULT
IDEAS OPENLY ANDESPECTFULLY IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE THE STATE OF
HUMANITY.
YALE IS COMMITTED TO THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF PROMOTING THE
PUBLIC'S TRUST IN CHECK
RESEARCH, EXPERTISE, AND THE
VALUE OF HIGHER EDUCATION BY
ENSURING THAT MR. HATCH'S
EXPERIENCE IS TYPICAL OF EVERY
STUDENT, EVERY DAY, IN EVERY
CLASSROOM.
PHILOSOPHY 181 REFLECTS THIS
RESPONSIBILITY.
IN HER COURSE, PHILOSOPHY AND
THE SCIEN OF HUMAN NATURE,
YALE'S FACULTY OF ARTS AND
SCIENCES DEAN TAMARA GENLER,
TIES COME COME COME COME --
CONTEMPORARY COGNITIVE SCIENCE,
HOW OUR MINDS OPERATE, TO WORK
OF ANCIENT PHILOSOPHERS.
THEY CONSIDER ANEW PLATO'S
ALLEGORY OF A CAVE, IN WHICH
PEOPLE MISTAKE SHADOWS ON THE
WALL FOR REALITY.
THE DEAN WALKS THE STUDENTS
THROH THIS ALLEGORY TO
CONSIDER THIS QUESTION:  HOW YOU
DISCOVER TRUTH GIVEN THAT THE
HUMAN MIND IS IMPERFECT?
OF COURSE, OUR LIMITATIONS POSE
NO IMPEDIMENT TO THE SEARCH FOR
TRUTH, FOR THEY ARE IN FACT WHAT
CAN POWER THE CURIOSITY
NECESSARY TO SUSTAIN IT.
BY EMBRACING OUR HUMILITY, WE
CAN BROADEN OUR UNDERSTANDING.
SO, AT YALE, WE WILL NOT NEARLY
REAFFIRM WHAT YOU ALREADY THINK
AS YOU ARRIVE.
WE WILL, INSTEAD, PROVOKE YOU TO
UNCOVER ALL YOU DID NOT KNOW
BEFORE YOU LEAVE.
WE WILL FINE-TUNE YOUR ABILITY
TO SIFT FACTS FROM FALSEHOOD FOR
THE CORE OF A LIBERAL EDUCATION
IS COMPROMISED OF REASON, LOGIC,
AND CRITICAL THINKING.
SOON YOU WILL BE THE BENEFICIARY
OF SUCH AN EDUCATION.
YET, IT BEHOOVES YOU, ALSO, TO
BE AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT IN IT.
AS STUDENTS.
AND THEN, IN DUE COURSE, AS
ALUMNI.
AND SO, TODAY, AS YOU BEGIN YOUR
COLLEGE CAREER, I CALL ON ALL OF
US TO PROMOTE A TRUTH-SEEKING
CLIMATE AT YALE IN EVERY
SEMINAR.
IN EVERY RESIDENTIAL COLLEGE.
AND IN EVERY LATE NIGHT
CONVERSATION.
TO ECHO OUR DEAN, BY BEING
WILLING TO ENTERTAIN IDEAS WITH
BY BEING WILLI TO EXTEND GRACE
AND ASSUME POSITIVE INTENT.
BY LISTENING CAREFULLY.
BY THINKING DEEPLY.
AND BY SPEAKING WITH EMPATHY AND
UNDERSTANDING.
LET US TOGETHER ELEVATE THE
VIRTUES OF TOLERANCE AND
ENGAGEMENT.
AND REJECT THE CULTURE OF PUBLIC
SHAMING, DOXXING, AND
OSTRACISM.
AND IN TIME-TESTED TRADITION,
LET US STRENGTHEN THE OPEN
DISCOURSE THAT HAS FOR CENTURIES
BEEN A HALLMARK OF OUR
INTELLECTUAL COMMUNITY AT YALE.
AND THAT HAS PRODUCED THE
SCHOLARSHIP AND SCIENTIFIC
BREAKTHROUGHS THAT HAVE IMPROVED
THE WORLD WELL BEYOND IT.
BY DOING SO, YOU CAN DEVELOP
EXPERTISE.
AND ALSO, HELP TO RESCUE ITS
STANDING.
YOU CAN, IN AN INCREASEINGLY
DARK WORLD, BRING VERI TAS TO
LOOKS.
AND PERHAPS EQUALLY AS VITAL, IN
A FRAGMENTED WORLD, BRING LOOKS
TO VERITAS.
LIGHT TO TRUTH.
WELCOME TO YALE!
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪ TIME PASSES QUICKLY HERE ♪
♪ EVERYTHING NEW ♪
♪ CHILDHOOD BEHIND US NOW ♪
♪ FADING FROM VIEW ♪
♪ FOUR YEARS STRETCH OUT BEFORE
US ♪
♪ HOPE RUSHING IN ♪
♪ JUST BREATHE IN AND CLOSE YOUR
EYES -- TIME TO BEGIN ♪
♪ RAISE YOUR VOICES HERE FOR AN
EVENING ♪
♪ RAISE YOUR VOICES WITH ME FOR
A TIM ♪
♪ RAISE YOUR VOICES AND IN THE
WEAVING ♪
♪ YOURS WILL LIFT THE SOUND OF
MINE ♪
♪ TIME PASSES QUICKLY STILL ♪
♪ PASSES QUICKLY ♪
♪ LIFE RICHLY DRAWN ♪
♪ WISDOM OF LESSONS LEARNED ♪
♪ YOUTH PASSING ON
♪ OUR BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS
UNFOLD ♪
♪ NEW MYST'RIES WITHIN ♪
♪ BUT ALWAYS THE SONG RINGS
OUT -- ONCE MORE BEGIN ♪
♪-- MORE BEGIN ♪
♪ RAISE YOUR VOICES HERE FOR AN
EVENING ♪
♪ RAISE YOUR VOICES WITH M FOR
TIME ♪
♪ RAISE YOUR VOICES AND IN THE
WEAVING ♪
♪ YOURS WILL LIFT THE SOUND OF
MINE ♪
♪ RAISE YOUR VOICES HERE FOR AN
EVENING ♪
♪ RAISE YOUR VOICES WITH ME FOR
A TIME ♪
♪ RAISE YOUR VOICES AND IN THE
WEAVING ♪
♪ YOURS WILL LIFT THE SOUND OF
MINE ♪
♪ THE SOUND OF... MINE ♪
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
CHAPLAIN KUGLER: AS WE READY
OURSELVES TO STEP OUT ON TOEW
GROUND IN THIS DAUNTING, YET
INSPIRING LIMBAL SPACE OF THE
UNKNOWN NEXT, WE BEGIN A
POIGNANT TURN OF GOOD-BYES AND
HELLOS THAT INVITE LAUGHTER,
TEARS, COLLEGE, CHOICE, DISCOVER
RY AND PRIDE.
LET US GO FORTH WITH DEEP TRUS
IN CERTAIN KNOWLEDGE.
THAT IN THIS PLACE EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF US IS WELCOME
THAT IN THIS PLACE WE WILL BOT
STUMBLE AND SOAR
.
THAT IN THIS PLACE LOVE
SURROUNDS US, BEAUTY CAN
SURPRISE US, IN THIS PLACE,
LIGHT AND TRUTH AWAITS US.
ON THIS DAY AND EVERYDAY FORWA
MAY ALL THAT IS HOLY SHINE UPON
US AND TENDERLY BLESS OUR EVERY
BREATH.
MAY WE GO IN SHALOM, IN SALAAM,
IN SHANTI.